Angela as you know is a former
astrologer yoga teacher Reiki
practitioner and Tarot reader who spent
nearly a decade engaged in New Age
spirituality before finding true
religion which is which is great and she
has a really interesting story which you
can listen to for a long period of time
on my YouTube channel that that's
available now I think it's at 1.1
million views you can go check that out
and now we welcome on
Angela Angela thank you for coming on
the show of course thanks for having me
back so I want to start with a topic we
can Branch off from there
but today is my day for
difficult truths where people are going
to want to shoot the messenger but I'm
just calling it like I sees it and we
were talking about this in the 2024
presidential race and I'm not going to
hold back and now I'm gonna have to
irritate
I think
a not insignificant percentage of the
audience
when I point out that yoga
is
bad
I know young white women even older
white women white women of a certain age
they love yoga but
no bueno no
um in fact a couple minutes ago when you
said speaking of people that insult
Their audience I thought that's how you
were introducing me because this insults
my audience more than any other topic
and it's really amongst Christians that
I get the most backlash from
and I have found that it is because
honestly I'm just going to come right
out and say it's because yoga is the
practice that invokes the most demons
so when you're practicing yoga
constantly you are entirely demonized
and so not only is your flesh kind of at
enmity with the truth of what yoga is
but the demons are too they don't like
to hear that
um and that's really why it gets the
most backlash but yeah it's not the
practice for Christians to be engaging
in
um I got this directly from the Indian
ministry of external Affairs which is
the government agency that's responsible
for implementing Indian foreign policy
they say that yoga is essentially a
spiritual discipline based on an
extremely subtle science which focuses
on bringing Harmony between mind and
body the practice of yoga leads to Union
of individual Consciousness with the
universal Consciousness and so thus the
aim of yoga is self-realization to
overcome all kinds of suffering leading
to the state of Liberation which they
call Moksha otherwise known as freedom
so it's about living with freedom in all
walks of life Health Harmony which would
be the objective main focus of the yoga
practice and so that's just like right
away completely antithetical to what the
Bible says we know that freedom comes
from Jesus Christ we know that John 8 36
836 if the sun sets you free you are
free indeed we know second Corinthians 3
17 the Lord is the spirit and where the
spirit of the Lord is there is freedom
and the spirit of the Lord is not
engaged in a Hindu practice straight up
um so
the yoga I always say is a and I think I
said this on your show is that yoga is a
spiritual practice with physical
benefits it is not a physical practice
with spiritual benefits and when you
really go back into
the roots of yoga because it's so
important to really understand these
things as they originate you come back
to this God this Hindu god known as
Shiva so Shiva is the first Yogi Guru in
the ancient yogic lore and he's also
known as Shiva the Destroyer or the God
of destruction which is funny when you
look at scripture how it says that the
enemy is his intention is to steal kill
and destroy so that's kind of
interesting
um but it's believed in the Hindu
religion and for context
um the religious worldview of Hinduism
surrounds the foundational Concepts
basically of Oneness and pluralism which
in and of itself is contradictory but
that's a discussion for another time
um so it's believed that Shiva destroys
the universe at the end of each two
billion year cycle which comes into its
own thing with reincarnation and other
things that we don't believe as
Christians and
he destroys the universe at the end of
each of those Cycles which allows for a
new creation which they call Brahma and
Brahma is known as the god of creation
so that's essentially saying our god
um of course again that's antithetical
to our world view
but the base this is the basis of yoga
because it's within this belief that
it's said that Shiva the Destroyer
taught yoga to the seven Great sages and
that was so that they could pass their
knowledge along to all of humanity and
so those seven Great sages are get this
the mind-born sons of Brahma of creation
so the sons of God
who do we know is the Son of God right
um so it's just this major Antichrist
spirit that is behind the the curation
the origination of the yoga practice The
Narrative of the yoga practice
um and we know I love to reference this
verse in terms of the yoga practice
First Corinthians 10 21 where it says
you cannot drink the cup of the Lord and
of the cup of demons you cannot partake
of the table of the Lord and of the
table of demons and that's exactly what
engaging in the yoga practice is you are
you are partaking of the cup of demons
and I don't care how dramatic it sounds
that's what scripture says and when you
look at the history when you look at The
Narrative of yoga when you look at the
foundations it is demonic it is Pagan it
is not of God it is of the devil because
if it's not of God it's of the other guy
okay now what do you say to our dear
liberal or even somewhat conservative
white women friends who say look man I
get it I'm even willing to agree with
you and maybe it's some weird like kind
of demon thing or whatever but
for
me I do before brunch on Sundays and so
I go I just stretch out my body it's I'm
not trying to commune with Spirits I'm
just trying to be a little peaceful and
like sweat in my Lululemon pans and then
I go get a smoothie and eggs benedict
and why you know if if I'm not engaging
with it if I don't consciously view it
that way then why is it bad if I kind of
you know stretch around and do the ohms
or whatever
all right so to that I say
um we know that the word says that the
heart is deceitful above all things
first and foremost so your intentions
are kind of irrelevant to that I mean
the the entire gospel alone proves that
how you know Jesus came for us because
we would never be able to
to get to heaven without him because we
are just innately Sinners and so I say
all the time that there is regardless of
your subjective intent there is always
an objective reality to the things that
you're participating in and I like to
use a very simple example of say a
single mom you know is struggling real
can't keep a roof over her head can't
feed her kids so she goes out and with
the best intentions she goes out and
Robs a Bank so that she has the money to
sustain her family
subjective intention good wants to
provide objective reality a crime should
not be doing that so I mean you know
apples and oranges but it's just it's
just the point is your subjective
intention does not negate the objective
reality this is such an important point
this is something a lot of people
misunderstand even about Christianity
but this is the essential point of the
sacraments is in our Modern Age we think
that all all that really matters is my
feelings you know or my intentions the
road to hell is paid with good
intentions were my mind space or my
vibes man or whatever and they fail to
observe that Christianity is not a
feeling and it's not a philosophy and
it's not a poem it's a fact right the
gospels are journalism they're not
they're not some work of fiction or
poetry or something like that and so in
the sacrament of baptism
you if you're being baptized and I don't
know the morning's news pops into your
head or you start thinking about how
much you look forward to the
cheeseburger after the baptism or I
don't know you're sort of thinking about
your cousin bill
and then the the priest baptizes you
and you say oh no I did it take I don't
know I wasn't in the right mind space
man what people are confusing is
the preeminence of objective reality
over subjective feeling the the person
who is doing the acting in baptism is
not you it's the Holy Spirit that's the
when Christ goes and he heals the sick
it's not the sick who we're acting it's
Christ who is acting when the priest
forgives sins who sends you forgive or
forgiven who sends you retainer retain
it's not you who is acting I mean your
your penitent obviously you're
requesting Absolution but it is it is
outside of you and that that is very
liberating I just in a lot of new age
practices you know it a lot better than
I do
it seems like the whole point of it is
just to focus yourself on yourself
and with yoga specifically it's it's it
I mean that's true because it's
ritualistically designed by means of
Enlightenment and it's
self-enlightenment
um I mean the primary the primary goal
of the creation of yoga
is salvation personal self-salvation and
So within the context of the Christian
worldview the result is I mean it's
inevitably blasphemous
just to be honest about it um because
Hinduism which is again yoga's founder
is the direct antithesis of everything
that the Bible says to be true and as
you just said you know the Bible what
the Bible says is Romans 10 Romans 10
9-10
um and so we don't we we just really
shouldn't be doing this and and I know
it sounds like well you why why can't I
stretch why can't I do this why can't I
do that I know it sounds innocuous but
that's how the devil loves to present
himself Second Corinthians 11 14 he
comes as an angel of Light everything
about yoga is presented as light and
love
there's a reason that the mindfulness
industry is like a 1.1 billion dollar
industry because it just capitalizes off
of this lie of light and love it
capitalizes off second Corinthians 11
14. I love that point I I just want to
hit it really briefly which is that
mindfulness and meditation we hear about
it all over the place it's in schools
now and even I I'm fairly attuned to
this stuff even I sometimes let it pass
but I think oh yeah mindfulness whatever
some hippie dippy thing but now of
course mindfulness and meditation that's
presented as light that's presented as
love but of course that isn't that I
want to get your take on the people who
are with you so far they say okay yeah
sure it's demon stuff okay maybe I
shouldn't do it maybe it's weird if
Christians engage in these liturgical
practices of non-Christian religions but
aren't all people just kind of moving
toward God meaning you know maybe we're
we think God is like a fire hose and
someone else thinks God is like a big
tree trunk but actually we're all just
kind of blind and we're just grabbing
different parts of the elephant you know
man and so I'm grabbing the nose and
someone's grabbing the leg but it's all
we're all kind of doing the same thing
isn't that not a lot less harsh you know
isn't that a lot nicer too and just kind
of more inclusive and welcoming
well
um
it goes back to what we were just
talking about like subjective intention
versus objective reality and how you
even said Christianity is a fact and I
mean it sounds harsh but the truth often
comes
not easily taken yeah it's not it's not
always easy to hear what is objectively
true
um
and as far as inclusivity goes it's it's
a moot point because the truth is there
there is no such thing as Oneness all
roads do not lead to God
the Bible says that broad is the road to
destruction but narrow leads to the gate
and so the narrow road is the is the
Christian lifestyle and I'm not saying
that because I want to be right I'm
saying that because I know God's word to
be true because I know God keeps his
promises I know he is faithful I know
that Jesus is who he says he is when he
says he is the way the truth and the
light you know Buddha said he is a true
Seeker Muhammad said he is a Prophet of
Truth Jesus said I am the truth and so I
just
I'm not here to make anyone feel better
and I don't say that from a place of
disrespect it's just I don't care about
your feelings I care about your eternity
I care about the your soul I care about
what's going to happen to you at at the
other side at the other side of this
life and I've said before on my own
podcast that
you know if someone was standing on a
street corner about to set themselves on
fire
you wouldn't just let them do it you
wouldn't just be like yeah go live your
truth if that's what if that's what you
need to do for yourself that that seems
like a great idea go ahead it's like no
you would take the match you would take
the gasoline and that's what I feel
most Christians I won't say all
Christians because there are Christians
that don't do it well but most
Christians that really want to
demonstrate the gospel
when we tell you about the word of God
that's what we are doing we are trying
to take the match and the gasoline from
you and tell you that there is a better
way because there is the way and that is
Jesus you know Penn Gillette who was an
atheist I think he might still be an
atheist he said or 15 20 years ago now
he said that he didn't have any respect
for Christians who don't proselytize
because he said if you really think that
I'm in danger of Hellfire then I should
hope you care enough about me to mention
that I'm maybe on the wrong path what do
you make of this objection from hamoto
Dragon who says quote everything I don't
like is just the devil and demonic
because sometimes sometimes it you know
when you talk about these things a lot
sometimes people think that you're just
uh
claiming that everything that doesn't
tickle your fancy is you know a red guy
with a tail and horns it's like satanic
Panic right so sin the things that we
tend to like as human beings are often
sinful and that does come from our
fallen nature which comes from the
result of a Fallen World which is the
devil's doing essentially the serpent in
the garden so um I mean that's not
necessarily a false thing to say
the things that we enjoy as as human
beings
are often sinful and thus their and thus
they're demonic you know if someone
enjoys going out and getting drunk every
night that's that's demonic because it's
just a blatant sin but but not all
things that we enjoy are that way I mean
maybe in this culture it's so easy to to
fall into because of concupiscence it's
so easy to fall into Pleasures that are
are vicious but if you practice virtue
and you try to turn away from that stuff
then one can derive a great deal of Joy
from taking a walk in a park playing
music or something like that right so
yeah I'm not saying you know taking a
walk in the park is demonic but you know
what I mean it's just like
within the context of things that um
I guess that that the Bible would
categorize as what we what what is
sinful
um taking on the walk in the park
spending time with your pets
that's not demonic but the the point
with yoga specifically is a completely
different animal from somebody enjoying
flying a kite taking a walk in the park
going parasailing surfing stuff like
that it's like
when the vine is Pagan the fruit cannot
be holy yeah um and so the the vine here
specifically with yoga if that's what
this person is alluding to something
that they enjoy doing
then the fruit of yoga if the vine is
Hindu and the fruit is Yoga so then we
take it from this point of view the vine
is Yoga so the fruit is idolatrous it's
false worship it's explicitly condemned
in the word of God and that just is what
it is and we in John 15 Jesus calls
himself the vine that's the only Vine
that we should abide in there's only one
Vine that produces holy fruit and apart
from him we can do nothing and so just
given the design the history and the
purpose and the definitions surrounding
yoga we can be assured that those
that the one whose Branch grows from the
practice is withered and thrown away
like we do see in John 15. I mean I'm
struck even by the language that people
use around this stuff because
there are going to be maybe more people
after this segment than before who say
okay uh you're right yoga I'm not going
to engage in it it's kind of weird it's
probably demonic it's not good for me
okay I'm not going to do it but I just
want to I just want to be at one with
the universe you know I just wanna I
just want to manifest good things you
know like I just want I just want to
feel some good vibes man I'm putting
Good Vibes out for you and you know it's
just like it's like a yin and yang you
know what I mean man and I'm being
slightly hyperbolic with the way I'm
using this language but people even
conservative people Christian people
traditional people
because language is so slippery
and because it's so prevalent in our
society and we're memetic creatures so
we just imitate what what other people
do they'll just use this language and
then the more you use that kind of
language the more it informs your your
view of the world because language
constitutes in many ways our view of the
world I I've heard people say hey can
you just pray to the universe man and I
think praying to the universe is
explicitly condemned by all of the
monotheistic religious views and of
course Christianity praying to the
universe is to pray to Creation which is
idolatry and I know you don't mean to
say that you're you you want to be
idolatrous but that's how slippery the
language can be
100 and I did say this on your show if
you go into a yoga studio that's what
you're going to hear them say is let's
you know Oneness with the universe let's
let's Channel our source energy it's not
going to be about God when when I was at
the tail end of my journey in New Age
when I was teaching yoga
and I was starting to wake up to the
truth of Christianity I tried to be like
well I'm going to be a Christian yoga
teacher which is a hilarious thing that
people like to say to me sometimes I'm
going to be a Christian yoga teacher so
I would try to talk about God and it was
just like it just struck the room in
such a way where it just did not belong
it because it was it's not of God so why
are you trying to bring God in God has
nothing to do with the yoga practice you
know it's really funny that you know I
mentioned at the beginning there's an
antichrist Spirit behind yoga and that's
true and it's actually called the
Kundalini spirit so there's something in
the yoga practice that they refer to as
the Kundalini Spirit often and it's
literally referred to as a coiled snake
that lives at the base of your spine and
three yeah a coiled snake we know what
the snake is and so through the yoga
practice this snake travels up through
your chakra system and this is this is
done through the particular asanas and
the asanas are the movements that you go
through
stretching by by the way I will just say
as a sidebar stretching and yoga are two
different things you can stretch just do
not stretch within the context of yoga
so so this I try not to do either though
just to be safe Angela I try not to just
to besides or you know work out in any
way there's plenty of ways to exercise
without channeling ancient deities so
just be really careful though I'm going
to be on the call I'm going to err on
the side of caution
this snake travels up through your
chakra system according to yoga and um
it's done through the the multiple poses
in the asanas and the intention with
that snake traveling up through your
spine and through your all your seven
chakras up through your head is to align
with a higher version of yourself and so
basically the Kundalini spirit is a
counterfeit Holy Spirit and so this
whole play of Satan with the with the
lore of the Kundalini Spirit In Yoga
it's crafty because it is an assault to
our very god-given design to Crave the
supernatural
um you know God gives us these yearnings
um because we are created for relational
intimacy with our creator but too often
we simply just don't want to invest the
time the fervent Bible study or a prayer
or you know Church going to really
witness that and so the you know the
timing with the Holy Spirit is always in
God's hands it's not by our demand and
so then here comes the false prophet of
the Kundalini Spirit of this this lore
of the yoga practice that's like oh I
can have it right now and so yoga is
just like a deception within that
context and you know it's funny it's
funny Angela because it's you know when
we say these things you know like yoga
is bad you know there's demons involved
don't do it then the the lib media break
it out they say listen to these crazy
people and I think you know look
obviously according to the modern
liberal view of things uh we probably
sound pretty wacky but we're not
innovative here in any way we're just
stating something that Christians have
believed for all of history and that the
Old Testament Jews believed before there
were such a thing as Christians and so
when you zoom out beyond the myopia of
of the last two decades or something of
pop culture and you look at the scope of
History our view is the consistent view
of the church forever I got in trouble
the other day because I pointed out that
uh artificial contraception is like
really bad and you shouldn't do it and
and headlines all over the place well
this crazy radical guy I think you know
I there's nothing Innovative about what
I just there's nothing original about
what I I just said I'm articulating the
view of the church for its entire
history you know if if people have a
little perspective on this I think
they'll notice that what is strange is
not the voices that are supposed
according to the mainstream media are
supposedly Fringe today by expressing
Eternal religious truths but maybe the
fringiest wackiest most bizarre people
are the ones engaging in all sorts of
kooky practices in our modern culture
that that are the ones that we are are
pointing to right now we gotta leave it
there Angela where can people find you
so you can find heaven and healing
podcast on YouTube apple and Spotify
um my Instagram is just my full name and
I do actually have like a two hour
episode all about the yoga practice if
people want to hear more excellent
Angela always wonderful to see you and I
would encourage people to go check out
our very long interview over at the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel and
we'll have to see you again very soon
foreign